There actually are B batteries, but they aren’t
something you’ll usually see stocked at
most stores any longer.
Since the invention of the battery, there
have been a pretty amazingly diverse number
of battery types used with different sizes/shapes/voltages/storage
capacities/etc., and also named a variety
of things.
This gave rise to the need for an industry
wide standard, particularly as the lack of
an international or even national standard
during WWI was problematic for the military.
As such, after WWI, the War Industries Board
and several other government agencies got
together to try to come up with standard specifications
for batteries.
A few years later, in 1928, the American Standards
Association, the predecessor to the American
National Standards Institute (ANSI), officially
adopted this proposal, introducing a list
of battery cell sizes and their corresponding
label.
For these labels, they used the suggested
convention that A would be the smallest; as
you went up in the letters, the batteries
would get larger in size.
There was also a “No. 6” battery that
was the largest.
This was just adopted as it had previously
been one of the most popular battery cell
sizes used (a 6 inch battery), so it was grandfathered
in, though now given more strict guidelines
to its exact specifications.
Others came along later, such as the AAA size,
which wasn’t adopted into the standard until
1959.
Since then, the ANSI standard for batteries
has been revised numerous times as battery
technology has evolved.
Why it appears there is no B (or A, F, etc.)
anymore is simply because those particular
battery sizes never really caught on commercially,
at least on the consumer end of things.
The ones that were most popular just ended
up being the AA, AAA, C, and D. Now-a-days,
because those are the most commonly available
to consumers, most manufactures continue to
use those battery types over the many other
sizes that are available to power their devices.
However, B batteries are still made and sold
and pack a decent punch for their size, 21.5
mm x 60 mm (.8464 in.
by 2.36 in.), producing 1.5 volts and 8350
mAh for the alkaline variety.
(For reference, standard alkaline AA’s ring
in at 1.5 volts and 2700 mAh).
‘A’ batteries are also still in production,
last most commonly used in early-model laptop
battery packs.
F batteries, on the other hand, are still
commonly used within something you can find
at your local supermarket- rectangular 6 volt
batteries.